which actors are in and which are out
who will take the Reigns and how does AI
factor into all of it Terminator 7 isn't
in production yet and here's why that
future never happened because I stopped
it when Terminator dark fate read its
head in 2019 it actually had a lot going
for it one of the biggest stting points
was a return of Sarah Connor herself the
incomparable Linda Hamilton as she
reunited with Arnold Schwarz and Egger's
T800 on screen for the first time since
Terminator 2 Judgment Day with the film
led by the brilliant McKenzie Davis as
brutal human machine hybrid Grace all
the ingredients were there for dark Fate
To Succeed the direct sequel to T2
ignored all the films from the last 20
years forging A New Path involving a
completely different robotic threat to
humanity called Legion same threat
different name but by the time the
credits rolled dark fate had backed
itself into a strange Corner after
killing off both Grace and swaren eggar
to mated T800 not to mention John Connor
himself Davis was meant to return in
future sequels as Grace but it would be
a new version of the character raised by
both Sarah Connor and future resistance
leader Danny Ramos played by Natalia
Reyes during Davis's 2020 appearance on
the happy sad confused podcast she
revealed how her robot killing hybrid
machine was originally set to return in
the planed sequels it was going to be a
sort of timeline thing will there be
another timeline that you'd explore like
there's no Resurrection but she came
from the future all these reboots are
enough to make Doug Brown's head hurt so
many timelines unfortunately for the
franchise dark fate wasn't the only
recent Terminator installments to do
poorly a decade prior the Terminator
Saga was going strong with a potential
blogbuster Trilogy spawning out of the
2009 film Terminator salvation and the
television series Terminator the Sarah
Conor Chronicles on the air it seemed as
if fans of the franchise were set to get
plenty of future Terminator content
unfortunately the Sarah Conor Chronicles
was cancelled after its second season
and despite the planed salvation sequels
the housian company was forced to sell
the franchise rights after a series of
financial troubles this eventually led
to Sky Dan and Paramount teaming up to
produce the Terminator Genesis reboot
which recast Sarah Connor and Kyle ree
now played by Amelia Clark and Ja
Courtney sparking a new timeline with
hopes of another Trilogy unfortunately
Genesis wasn't well received and all
planned sequels were soon cancelled
strangely franchise co-creator James
Cameron praised Genesis ahead of the
film's release calling the film The
Beginning of a franchise Renaissance
well in a way it was just maybe not the
way Cameron had orig hopes following the
disappointment that was Genesis Cameron
returned as a co-writer and producer for
dark face though even his presence
couldn't save the movie from becoming a
disaster despite previously praising
both Terminator Genesis and Terminator
dark Fate has being the true third
Terminator movie producer James Cameron
has since spoken out against the latter
installment telling deadline prior to
the release of Avatar the way of water I
think I'm actually reasonably happy with
the film I think the problem and I'm
going to wear this one is that I refuse
to do it with Al Arnold the producer
went on to explain that bringing back
Schwarzenegger as a T800 and director
Tim Miller's desire to bring back Linda
Hamilton as sarahana was in his opinion
the biggest issue he admitted it was
your granddad's Terminator movie and we
didn't see that and surprisingly Cameron
fails to note a longtime franchise fans
criticism of the film's new leads the
killing off of Edward furlong's John
Connor or even the half-hearted attempts
by dark fate to do the same thing that
the first two Terminator films did over
30 years ago it wasn't the cast that was
a problem it was a lack of Creative
Vision Cameron told the smart Les
podcast back in 2021 if I were to do
another Terminator film and maybe try to
launch that franchise again which is in
discussion but nothing has been decided
I would make it much more about the AI
side of it the bad robots gone crazy
well that seems like a step in the right
direction it might not be enough James
Cameron isn't the only one to feel that
Arnold Schwarz and Egger's involvement
in the last two Terminator movies was a
mistake it seems like the governator
thinks so too after heels of his recent
three-part Netflix documentary Arnold
the former Terminator star revealed that
he won't be back for another installment
as vista baby previously Schwarzenegger
has been involved in every theatrical
installment of the franchise with the
exception of Terminator Salvation since
he was serving as the governor of
California at the time although his
likeness was still used in the third Act
of the film Arnold told The Hollywood
Reporter in May 2023 the franchise is
not done I'm done I got the message loud
and clear that the world wants to move
on with a different theme when it comes
to the Terminator someone just has to
come up with a great idea the actor went
on to elaborate that he loved the first
three movies but that the last two
weren't well written of course nobody
can blame Arnold for not wanting to be
involved in the franchise he helped
ignite but youd think that he might have
wanted to voice those concerns years ago
well it's hard to think about what the
future of the Terminator franchise could
look like without him both Terminator
salvation and the television series
Terminator the Sakana Chronicles told
interesting unique stories with out
Schwarz and Egger's involvement
continuing without Arnold may not be
ideal but it's certainly possible
possibly the most shocking news in the
development of a possible 7th Terminator
movie came from James Cameron himself
following his appearance at D
Technologies World 2023 according to a
tweet by an employee who works for Dell
Technologies Cameron lets slip that he
began writing the next Terminator movie
months prior but that he's waiting for
new developments on the fast changing AI
landscape before he gets too deeply into
it no doubt the rising artificial
intelligence as of late certainly Mak
the world of Terminator feel a bit more
real and might even make continuing the
series a bit more complicated
nevertheless Cameran who wrote and
directed The Terminator and its sequel
terminated to Judgment day before
stepping away from the series has
progressively gotten more involved in
the franchise in recent years he first
helped promote 2015's Terminator Genesis
and then produced and contributed to the
story of Terminator dark fate maybe
after so many failures and creative
differences from the franchise's
original intent Cameron is finally ready
to fully take back the Reigns and rest
saw his original Creative Vision but
given how long fans waited for a sequel
to 2009's Avatar it's entirely possible
that we could be waiting a Whole Decade
for another Terminator movie who knows
you may even want to see the next three
Avatar sequels through first before
pursuing Another Science Fiction epic
either way Cameron returning as a
primary screenwriter sounds like good
news even if his work on the last movie
wasn't remotely his best the big
question when considering a seventh
installment in the convoluted Terminator
series is whether or not the next movie
should be a re boots or a continuation
now it's unlikely that whatever sequel
James Cameron comes up with will connect
to any of the previous centuries or the
failed trilogies Terminator Salvation
connects too much to Terminator 3 rise
of the Machines Terminator Genesis built
its own revised timeline with actors
uninterested in returning and Terminator
dark fate was largely hated by fans so
what could be next because of the nature
of the series alternate timelines are
not outside the realm of possibility
when it comes to another Terminator
movie for years fans have hoped for a
dark and gritty look at the fure future
war that Cameron teased all those years
ago and now that he's back helming the
franchise maybe it's time to see that
war in full view going forward it would
be an easy way to connect the original
films to Cameron's New Vision after all
and highlighting Kyle ree again would be
a nice change after so many years of
following Sarah conversely if Cameron
wants to further explore our modern
concepts of AI then setting the film in
the present might make more sense how
could Skynet be born now that's a
question worthy of an answer even if
Genesis already provided one either way
a reboot is necessary since Linda
Hamilton isn't particularly interested
in returning a Sarah Connor either at
this point Terminator 7 could happen but
it doesn't seem very likely after the
disappointing box office reception for
dark fate making just $261 million on a
$185 million budget it seems like the
franchise's Fate has been sealed it's
disappointing since James Cameron was
intending to write future sequels after
producing dark fate and given the
franchise's recent Reliance on CGI it
would have been interesting to see if
Cameron could could have brought it back
to its practical effects rout we all
remember when we first saw a fake
schwarzen Egger head cut out its own
eyeball in The Terminator arguably a
bigger question here is whether
audiences even want to see a terminat 7
actress McKenzie Davis thinks that
audiences are bard of the franchise
which isn't surprising since the six
films have exhausted a number of
different methods of continuation
sequels hard reboots and soft reboots as
Davis told nme in 2020 I really Lov the
dark fate and I'm so proud of what we
did but there was to demand for it at
the box office and to think that there'
be a demand for a seventh film is quite
insane you should just pay attention to
what audiences W maybe the issue isn't
that fans don't want more Terminator
stories they're just holding out for
good ones and there hasn't been one for
quite some time there is no
fate but what we make for
[Music]
ourselves